für mein empfinden mit große gewaltig
können das heißt es denn deutschland
gemeinsam machen es aber keinen satz
dieses gewusel macht mich
irgendwann kommt der punkt an dem du
weißt so wie es ist darf es nicht
bleiben das fängt an wie ein spiegel tv
reportage
studenten mit assad terminator
liegengeblieben zu viel verschossen hier
wird ja auch eine durchgängig genutzt
von herrn lindner habe er duzt sich
selber nicht mehr christian lind noch
sagt damit zu sich selbst
das ist natürlich ein mittel der
kreidezeit tun kann man sagen aber tief
in die er weißt du dass es jetzt sein
muss der hart arbeitende christian
lindner nach ihm auf die äppelwoi
ausgeguckt schon wieder im gang ist
schon wieder einsam ich würde sagen noch
in der regel der einzelnen männer sieht
er natürlich in kool savas
denkt man möchte ich nicht persönlich
werden aber hier guckt man wirklich in
die augen eines tieftraurigen elefanten
ja schon einfach zu lange dabei ist es
trifft ein wirklich tief ins herz
digitalisierung ist das über lebensthema
für gesundheit für arbeitsplätze
ein bisschen
schuldig noch sozial
das ist das bild das haben die grünen
leider vergessen das wäre schon also das
hätte dazu gehört kein schöner land
christian lindner pflanz einen baum er
rief lasst natürlich nicht nur einen
baum pflanzt einen setzling ist das neue
jahr ach ist das schön eine starke
wirtschaft ist es
unsere kinder wollen und brauchen
dringend bildung auf höhe letzte diese
kinder sehen in der tat aus als
bräuchten sie dringen bildung völlig
verwahrlost sitzen sie da irgendwie
nicht abgeholt wahrscheinlich schule
unterricht schwänzen mit freude am
erfinden nicht an verbieten
im grunde art großer tv spot ist ganz
gut drauf einem die welt nicht hässlich
zu zeigen und trotzdem zu sogar während
das kann ja noch nicht alles sein die
welt muss sich ändern ist nicht
selbstverständlich immer scheint etwas
anderes wichtiger
das fundament
und das angst beschäftigt sich bis tief
in die nacht er ist obwohl es dichten
hat mich daher ist das also diese
er ist kein digitaler dichter und denker
können sagt nick
und das ist mir eigentlich ganz gut
aber die frage was
als diese bilder sollen von segelboot
tätowierte
was macht ihr pilates crunches oder
bauchmuskeln auf der treppe und der
alten frau am fenster das ist so eine
bilderfolge g leuchtet mir gar nicht ein
im zusammenhang mit freiheit es sind
also was er und es gibt noch einen einen
surfer zwischendrin
und das alles beschäftigt dich bis tief
in die nacht
interessant an diesem video ist wenn es
hoffentlich wirklich nicht an uns liegt
das für digitalisierung geworben wird
man aber das gefühl hat das internet sei
so ruckelig
dass dieses video gar nicht für sich
laufen kann warten wir nicht länger
nie gab es mehr zu tun der
offensichtlichste widerspruch in der
inszenierung diese spots ist der
christian lindner suggeriert auch er
würde für uns hier arbeiten man sieht
ihn ja ständig wie er bis tief in die
nacht
sich für uns einsetzt
meines wissens hat aber christian
lindner gar kein regierungsamt in seinem
trivialen wahlkreisbüro wird er nicht
gezeigt sondern natürlich wie so ein
super checker im fond einer limousine
zwischen zwei terminen und irgendwie
wartet man darauf dass benicio del toro
aus chicago vorbei kommt und sagt schöne
grüße von guadalajara kartell mich jetzt
nicht überzeugt ästhetisch einmal sowie
sony music aussehen also wirklich sehr
altbacken aus weil es so jung und
dynamisch sein bisschen glück schon auch
in diesem selbstgespräch finde ich
eigentlich dass es die die eitelkeit von
christian lendner nochmal ganz besonders
herausstellt und
ich glaube ihm das eigentlich alles
überhaupt nicht ich lasse mich ein
bisschen ratlos zurück seine
tiefe traurigkeit
die aus diesen
springenden
standbildern
heraus schimmert